from a director who watched the menu I'm
an annoying social media influencer and
a studio exec whose nephew saw a Glass
Onion I come from old money don't look
me in the eye five obnoxious caricatures
meet the situation of their nightmares
I've invited all of you to this island
in order to to eat us yeah actually
that's you hit the nail on the head
that's what I'm going to do to you no I
have to tweet this it's the movie
critics are calling incredibly obvious
and this isn't about me I'm an annoying
critic I'm a snob I I suck oh this
might be about me I'm the tech bro slash
Elon Musk Jeff Bezos stand in let's
innovate and synergize bro let's do some
constructive brain solving or I could
eat you ooh that's gonna hurt in the
morning if you love takedowns of the
wealthy without any deeper critiques of
capitalism You're Gonna Love we get it
guys haha we totally relate I'm the
working class stand in how could you
tell I enjoy eating cheeseburgers